why is South Korea's government making
BTS serve in the military I mean yeah
it's required under South Korean law
that able-bodied men serve in the
military for two years but I mean come
on they're BTS famous people are always
able to like pull strings and like get
out of stuff like this right on this
case the head of the military Manpower
Department said that it would be quote
desirable for them to serve in the name
of fairness they're trying to like lay a
precedent like hey everyone needs to
serve including the Rich and Famous
which I guess that's fair literally and
yeah we all hate the rich people who get
out of doing what we all have to do but
in this case it's different they're like
a National Treasure they have brought so
much Prestige and attention and revenue
to this country but on the other hand
you got to kind of set a precedent here
South Korea's military has been running
low on service members mainly because of
dropping birth rates and by dropping
birth rates I mean the lowest fertility
rate on Earth perhaps this is a good
idea let BTS serve in the military and
re-energize people's view of military
service what do you think should BTS
have to serve in the military is it
worth it let me know